oh gosh I I hate the way it was edited
the trailer so you said you're not ready
to date then you bring this guy in
you're not my type
[Music]
hurt or affect me if we had just met but
like I mean you look through the whole
journey and you're like yeah what like
this is it almost felt a little evil to
kind of string you along the whole time
you're not the type you know and so I I
felt like a little more shocked on that
sense
um but like as a friend like there's no
animosity or anything in between that
because I'm like when dating happens
things get a little sloppy you know even
in friendships things get sloppy
add dating on top of that we know what
we were getting into but I also just
didn't think it would end that way I
thought it'd be like other stuff you
know I don't understand my Instagram is
going off right now like you are so
harsh on him people don't realize is
that if you really pay attention and
watched since season one he I've
mentioned this many times he tried to go
for Kelly
which is a huge red flag rate I never go
for a guy that's tried to you know hit
on my girlfriend that was a red flag and
then he kept pushing me pushing me I'm
like no I don't really want to go there
and then
but then we have chemistry at the same
time he's a Charming guy he's a good
looking guy right it's a Leo in him and
then he reels you in and then I'm like
but then I know he's I I just know okay
I just know he's dating other girls too
and so I was kind of like all right
let's go all right let's you want to
play let's do the LIE detecting test my
question about feelings about a last
boyfriend it's scoring her as deception
indicated which means
lie and I asked the wrong questions and
I failed it it wasn't supposed to be
like that and and then and then and then
I look like a bad person again and then
and then later I needed a break from
everything I brought Louis on and
it was almost kind of like a get back or
I admit that part it was like being a
little petty kind of like huh I'm not
just gonna bring another gum I'm gonna
bring another guy with abs and as
somebody that Kevin doesn't not really
like for whatever reason and he was just
pushing me to the point where I finally
went off and just said you know what
um you're not my type run somewhere I
think you helped him as well because he
found his right I had to do that I know
it sounded like you know but sometimes I
mean true whether it's true you know you
know
look where he's at now he hopefully
found his true love so yeah story of
redemption you know I think it was uh
wonderful to see someone that um I was
in love with and come back into my life
and uh we get a fresh start which is
awesome what though oh hell no okay
Andrew I'm in shock right now that's
awkward I think I was shocked but so was
everybody else I mean in a million years
I would never think that he will I will
see him there and Anna will bring him
there out of everybody so I still have
no idea what happened there I think we
got a closure
but we got our closure when we're when
we're off season you know
um so you know I wish him the best and
yeah I wish him the best and I was I'm
really grateful that relationship
because I've learned a lot of myself I
think I blocked out of my memories I'm
like what happened
he was staring no
um yeah it was I definitely got upset
maybe a little too upset no I've never
seen Kelly like I'm like Anna you're
gonna send her back to therapy again so
I was like why like she looked
devastated like honestly I'm gonna Kelly
for so long and when I saw her like her
face I was like what happened to The
Independent Women like she just looked
shattered and you know it was it was a
tough it was a tough I thought they were
gonna get back no no way too much
crying I was like oh my God
this is not a notebook this one this is
a boxing notebook I'll be honest with
you a lot a lot of people are not gonna
agree but I have faith in them I thought
you know because why this because they
had so much history together one of the
things that really bothered me was that
I texted his mom for help keep reaching
out to reaching out calling and texting
no response back a few days later she
finally accepts me to hack finishes this
and she says I can't be there for Andrew
and he's emotional
outreaches you can tell like he has a
lot of love for her she does too but we
don't know how their relationship is
that's the way I mean there was never a
short of love in our relationship before
um but it just said you know I think
he's a good person and I just don't
think we're right for each other you
know because sometimes just two good
people just not right for each other
yeah it just brings out the worst in
each other that is true I've set up um
dating profile for you on an app I'm
gonna get you laid I think she's so
happy and uh you know hopefully I think
I'll let her be happy and private before
we spill the beans but she's really
happy I'm not single woman
could have been here the Andrew question
just like okay whatever it was like past
life I definitely found them
always like when you find the one you
know and I'm like this is the YouTube
for you tonight yeah this is
true when you find the one you just know
oh yeah really good guys out there I was
so jaded but they're still really good
guys out there I think he's everything I
ever wanted and plus more and they just
made everything I went through all worth
it so you have some news for us I do and
I'm really sorry but it's not good news
so the embryos that we're watching have
arrested meaning they've stopped growing
okay so we're not going to have anything
to biopsy or test and so we're not going
to have any embryos um for a future
pregnancy while Baby G asked if he could
have a baby sister and I said that was
impossible and he said can we go to the
shop and buy one and I didn't even know
what to say about that
um so
I mean I got a baby brother out of this
process so I'm really grateful and I I
think I'm going to continue drawing
[Applause]
[Music]
only Kevin and Mimi came to support me
on Dancing With the Stars Kelly was so
busy couldn't spare an extra second but
here she is having this easy breezy
relaxing girls weekend out in the middle
of nowhere but here I am
in the middle of nowhere with my
so-called friends I actually wanted to
go because I had no really you can laugh
all you want I wanted to go because I
wanted to see because I know she could
dance she has Rhythm yeah but it's just
I was busy and and then at the same time
none of the let's be honest none of you
guys wanted to go I didn't I told her
I'm joking
guys I mean I'm busy I love this
interview oh my God crying
[Music]